El objetivo de este video y del siguiente es
empezar a entender la idea de la escala de la
Tierra y del Sistema Solar, pues como veremos
cuando hablemos de la galaxia y el universo,
se vuelve casi imposible de imaginar, pero al
menos intentaremos hacer nuestro mejor esfuerzo.
Creo que la mayoría de los que vemos este video
sabemos que esto de aquí es la Tierra, esto de
aquí es la Tierra, y sólo para empezar a darnos
una idea de la escala, pienso que probablemente la
mayor distancia con la que tenemos alguna relación
cercana son unos 160 kilómetros. Puedes manejar
tu carro por una hora, hora y media, y recorrer
alrededor de 160 kilómetros, y en la Tierra eso
sería más o menos esta distancia, sería un puntito
que se vería más o menos como esto, estos son 160
kilómetros. Y también, para tener una mejor
idea de la escala, pensemos en una velocidad
que podamos comprender, y eso quizá podría ser la
velocidad de una bala. La velocidad de una bala y,
bueno, tal vez no la podemos comprender,
pero quizás es la cosa más rápida que podemos
identificar de alguna manera. La velocidad de
una bala es aproximadamente, y bueno, claro,
hay diferentes tipos de balas dependiendo del
tipo de arma y todo eso, pero podemos decir que
va aproximadamente a 280 m/s, que son unos 1,000
km/h. Y, bueno, esta velocidad es aproximadamente
la misma velocidad de un avión, de un jet. Y bien,
sólo para darles una idea de la escala aquí, la
circunferencia de la Tierra, si quisieras darle la
vuelta a la Tierra, la circunferencia de la Tierra
justo así, tiene alrededor de 40,000 kilómetros,
40 mil kilómetros, por lo tanto, si viajaras a
la velocidad de una bala o a la velocidad de
un jet que son 1,000 kilómetros por hora, te
tomaría 40 horas para circunnavegar la Tierra, 40
horas para dar la vuelta a la Tierra. Y creo que
tal vez ninguna de esta información es demasiado
sorprendente. Tal vez hayas tomado un vuelo de 12
o 15 horas y ese vuelo no le da toda la vuelta
a la Tierra, pero puedes llegar bastante lejos,
por ejemplo, de San Francisco a Australia o algo
así. Así que hasta ahora estas escalas no son muy
descabelladas, aunque hasta para mí la Tierra en
sí misma es un objeto extraordinariamente grande.
Ahora bien, pensemos un poco en el Sol. El Sol
empieza a ser algo inmenso. Aquí tenemos el Sol
y creo que la mayoría de las personas pueden
apreciar que el Sol es más grande, mucho más
grande que la Tierra, y que está bastante lejos de
ella. Sin embargo, no creo que la mayoría de las
personas, incluyéndome a mí, pueda realmente
apreciar qué tan grande es el Sol o qué tan
lejos está de la Tierra; así que para darles una
idea la circunferencia del Sol es 109 veces la
circunferencia de la Tierra, la circunferencia
del Sol es 109 veces la circunferencia de la
Tierra. Así que si hacemos el mismo ejercicio
mental y decimos "Bien, si viajo a la velocidad
de una bala o de un jet y me toma 40 horas dar la
vuelta al mundo, entonces ¿cuánto tiempo tardaría
en darle la vuelta al Sol?" Si pudiéramos viajar
alrededor del Sol en un avión, o si de alguna
forma pudiéramos viajar en una bala e intentara
circunnavegar el Sol, entonces nos tomaría 109
veces más de lo que nos toma circunnavegar la
Tierra, así que sería aproximadamente 100 veces.
Podemos decir de 109, pero pondremos 100 sólo para
aproximarnos más fácilmente: aproximadamente 100
veces la circunferencia de la Tierra. Así que, 100
x 40 es 4,000, 4,000 horas. Y sólo para comprender
cuánto es 4,000 horas, bueno, como tengo la
calculadora aquí haremos el cálculo exacto,
son: 109 veces la circunferencia de la Tierra,
109 x 40 horas, que es lo que nos llevaría a
viajar alrededor de la circunferencia de la
Tierra, esto nos da como resultado 4,360 horas
para circunnavegar el Sol yendo a la velocidad de
una bala o de un jet. Y si un día tiene 24 horas,
entonces son 181 días, nos tomaría alrededor de
medio año viajar alrededor del Sol a la velocidad
de un jet. Vamos a escribirlo: medio año. El Sol
es inmenso, el Sol es inmenso. Esto puede o puede
no sorprendernos, pero para tener una mejor idea
de la escala, tengo este otro diagrama del Sol,
y hablaremos más sobre el resto del Sistema Solar
en el próximo video. Pero aquí, en esta escala,
el Sol, al menos en mi pantalla, si tuviera que
completarlo tendría 50 centímetros de diámetro,
mientras que la Tierra es esta cosita pequeña
por acá, más pequeña que una gota de lluvia,
es esta cosita pequeña, si fuera a dibujarlo
en esta escala en la que el Sol es más pequeño,
la Tierra sería esto, la Tierra sería de este
tamaño. Ahora, lo que no es obvio, porque todos
hemos hecho nuestros proyectos de ciencia en
tercero y cuarto grado y siempre vemos este tipo
de diagramas del Sistema Solar, lo que no es obvio
es que los planetas están mucho más lejos. Ojo,
aunque estos planetas sí están representados
a escala, están mucho más lejos del Sol,
mucho más lejos de lo que aquí parece. Así que la
Tierra está a 150 millones de kilómetros del Sol,
es decir, si este es el Sol, justo aquí,
en esta escala, no podrías ver la Tierra,
no sería ni un pixel, pero estaría a 150 millones
de kilómetros de la Tierra; y esta distancia de
aquí se llama una unidad astronómica. Estaremos
utilizando este término en los próximos videos
sólo porque es una manera más fácil de pensar en
esta distancia, a veces abreviado como UA. Y sólo
para darles una idea de qué tan lejos es esto a la
luz, que creemos que es casi infinitamente rápida,
a la luz le toma 8 minutos viajar desde el Sol
hasta la Tierra. Si desapareciera el Sol, nos
tardaríamos 8 minutos en darnos cuenta o, dicho de
otra manera, para ponerlo en términos del jet, si
sacamos la calculadora otra vez, tenemos 150, eso
es miles, y con otros tres ceros más son millones:
150 millones de kilómetros, y si vamos a 1,000
kilómetros por hora, nos tomaría 150 mil horas
a la velocidad de una bala o de un jet para
llegar al Sol. Para poner esto en perspectiva,
si lo sacamos en días: sabemos que el día tiene
24 horas, entonces serían 6,250 días, y si lo
dividimos entre 365, tenemos aproximadamente 17
años. Si disparas una bala al Sol, le tomaría
17 años llegar allá si de alguna manera pudiera
mantener esa velocidad, claro. Vamos a escribirlo:
le tomaría 17 años a una bala o a un avión
llegar hasta el Sol. Otra forma de visualizarlo
es la siguiente: este Sol de aquí tiene unos
15 centímetros de diámetro en mi pantalla,
si realmente quisiéramos posicionarlos a escala,
esta manchita de aquí es la Tierra, este punto,
entonces, si quisiéramos dibujar la distancia a
escala, tendríamos que poner este punto a unos
15 metros de distancia del Sol, entre 15 y 18
metros de distancia del Sol. Si estuviéramos
mirando el Sistema Solar, y obviamente hay otras
cosas en el Sistema Solar, hablaremos más de ellas
en el siguiente video, si estuviéramos mirando
el Sistema Solar, ni siquiera veríamos el punto,
sería una partícula de polvo volando alrededor
del Sol; y mientras avancemos más y más fuera
del Sistema Solar, veremos que aún esta
distancia es ridículamente pequeña. Otra
forma de pensar es que si el Sol fuera de este
tamaño, entonces este punto, es decir, la Tierra,
que está a esta escala, estaría aproximadamente a
60 metros de distancia de él. Imaginemos un campo
de fútbol americano. Si tuviéramos un campo de
fútbol americano. Vamos a dibujarlo. Estas son
las zonas de anotación, una aquí y otra acá, y si
metiéramos algo un poco más grande que una pelota
de básquetbol en una de las zonas de anotación,
entonces este pequeño punto estaría alrededor
de 60 metros de distancia, no notarías algo de
ese tamaño en la escala de un campo de fútbol.
Pero bueno, los voy a dejar por aquí. Espero
que te empiece a maravillar pensar tan sólo en
las escalas del Sol, la Tierra, y qué tan lejos
está la Tierra del Sol. Luego vamos a ver que
aún estas distancias, que aún estas escalas, son
súper pequeñas cuando empecemos a pensar en el
resto del Sistema Solar, y especialmente
cuando vamos más allá del Sistema Solar.